durant tout le mois de janvier TV 78
reçoit les maires de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de l'année 2023 dans
leur commune ce soir nous recevons
Philippe guilgen bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes le maire des Clayes-sous-Bois
est également l'un des vis président de
50 ans en Yvelines alors une thématique
qui revient énormément en ce moment
c'est la sobriété énergétique comment ça
se passe dans votre commune Philippe
guygan quelles sont les actions que vous
mettez en place nous avons des actions
que nous avons débuté dès le printemps
de 2022 des actions qui se sont traduits
par différents éléments concrets comme
des mesures de réduction de température
dans la maxime le maximum de bâtiments
de notre de notre commune néanmoins nous
avions des marges de manœuvre peu
élevées parce que nous avions déjà
anticipé ces réductions de température
pour faire des économies sur les années
antérieures nous avons essayé de déjà
d'anticiper un certain nombre de
possibilités par exemple sur les
panneaux solaires de voir nous avons
contacté des sociétés pour voir si nous
pouvions mettre à disposition des
bâtiments de la ville pour pouvoir avoir
de
l'énergie nous avons pris des mesures
comme beaucoup de nos collègues comme
tout nos collègues de 51 Yvelines sur la
réduction des horaires d'éclairage la
nuit par exemple aux Clayes-sous-Bois ça
sera de 1h30 à 14h30 de manière à être
homogène avec les lignes de bus qui
parcourt qui parcourent notre ville nous
avons aussi fait des travaux d'isolation
déjà dans les bâtiments de la ville des
travaux d'isolation que nous avons pu
faire conformément à nos budgets nous
avons priorisé sur certains grands
projets comme la réhabilitation d'une
école les travaux des isolation dès le
premier exercice de travaux de manière à
essayer de réduire au maximum toutes ces
toute cette facture énergétique et cela
se traduit donc par une première réunion
publique à la fin du mois de novembre
avec notre population et un plan
énergétique qui va se décliner sur les
différentes allées parce que nous allons
prendre des mesures au fil de l'eau une
autre réunion est prévue avec les
habitants une autre réunion sera prévue
à la fin de ce de ce trimestre ou au
début du prochain trimestre et quels
sont les propositions justement des
habitants sur ce sur ce sujet là les
habitants pour l'instant ils ont fait un
constat avec nous nous leur avons dit
que nous avions anticipé nous les avons
mis devant les différentes possibilités
sachant que ces différentes possibilités
ne peuvent pas se réaliser en un mois
deux mois ou même six mois il faut faire
des études préalables par exemple la
géothermie la géothermie qui peut être
anticipée sur le territoire de 50 ans
c'est pour cela que nous allons nous
associer bien entendu à l'étude de notre
de notre agglomération les panneaux
solaires que j'ai cité tout à l'heure
tout ça nécessite des études pour
pouvoir si il y a un un homme de
rentabilité par rapport à
l'investissement et puis après il y a
des mesures concrètes comme je vous ai
cité les réductions de température la
priorisation sur un certain nombre de
travaux dans le budget 2023 que nous
allons voter de manière à essayer de
limiter au maximum cette facture
énergétique on en parle de plus en plus
de ce cette thématique avec le contexte
environnemental mais aussi la hausse des
prix de l'énergie c'est une thématique
qui inquiète les siennes et les
chrétiens aussi les commerçants qui sont
présents dans votre ville alors c'est
une thématique qui inquiète tout le
monde depuis la commune jusqu'au
jusqu'aux habitants j'ai personnellement
en discuté avec ma boulangère qui elle
avait la chance entre guillemets d'avoir
un contrat qui augmentait de plusieurs
dizaines de %, ce qui est déjà énorme
mais qui n'étaient pas multiplié par 5
ou par 10 comme l'ont comment certains
donc cela inquiète tout le monde bien
entendu donc justement est-ce que vous
allez organiser aussi une réunion avec
les gros consommateurs les bailleurs les
commerçants ce qui vraiment consomment
énormément énergie alors cette réunion
aujourd'hui n'est pas prévue en tant que
en tant que réunion par contre nous
incitons bien entendu les bailleurs à
essayer de d'optimiser toutes ces toutes
ces factures énergétiques les
commerçants avec ma délégué au Commerce
dans la commune nous prenions des
informations mais une réunion factuelle
en tant que telle à ce jour n'est pas
prévu mais sera néanmoins programmé
lorsque nous aurons des informations
concrètes sur ce qui attend au niveau
des commerçants puisque les commerçants
comme nous-mêmes dans les communes nous
avons pas aujourd'hui encore de
situations très très claires sur ce que
nous allons payer dans les mois ou dans
les semestre à bien alors sur un autre
sujet Philippe Guyenne vous avez été
reçu en septembre dernier à Bercy pour
évoquer la dégradation de la situation
économique dans les communes où on est
ce dossier vous aviez fait plusieurs
demandes où est-ce que ça en est alors
cette cette visite à Bercy pour moi a
permis de vraiment remonter le
mécontentement d'un certain nombre de
communes moyennes comme la mienne celle
des Clayes-sous-Bois ce sont des
communes où finalement nous avons en
général quasiment pas d'aide et où nous
devons en général également contribuer à
quasiment tout donc il était important
que l'on remonte les difficultés de ces
communes comme la nôtre que ça soit pour
la partie énergétique que ça soit sur
les sur les aides en général alors pour
moi cette démarche a permis déjà de
remonter la situation des élus de
terrain avec leur commune et je pense
que dans un premier temps nous avons
déjà été écoutés est-ce que nous allons
être entendu nous le verrons s'il y a
des mesures très concrètes qui nous sont
retournés dans les semaines ou les mois
à venir pour l'instant pas de retour
pour l'instant pas de retour concret si
ce n'est que nous avons quand même fait
passer le message et nous attendons le
véritable concret sur les factures
énergétiques au niveau électricité
au niveau gaz je dois dire que je suis
en train de bâtir notre budget
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas encore les
chiffres définitifs mais nous avons
l'impression que par rapport à ce que
nous craignons de hausse un moment donné
nous avons de très très fortes hausses
mais disons pour parler trivialement un
peu moins pire vous êtes inquiet
justement
sur les lacs concernant les finances
dans votre commune on peut être inquiet
dans la mesure où une commune comme la
mienne ou en tant que ancien adjoint au
finance cela fait 12 ans que j'avais
gelé les taux communaux donc cela fait
12 ans nous essayons de faire un maximum
d'économies dans tous les domaines quand
l'on voit une facture énergétique qui
explose comme comme cela explose dans
différentes communes pour une pour une
ville comme Les Clayes-sous-Bois
aujourd'hui la simulation d'augmentation
du gaz et d'électricité même s'il n'est
pas encore totalement définitive elle va
se situer entre 900 000 euros et un
million d'euros nous devons faire face
aussi à toute l'inflation
généralisée nous avons eu l'an dernier
l'augmentation du point d'indice et je
m'en félicite pour tous les tous les
collaborateurs de la ville mais tout ça
fait une somme financière qui
effectivement ne peut que nous inquiéter
alors concernant la sécurité la police
municipale des Clayes-sous-Bois va
bientôt fusionner avec celle de plaisir
alors c'était une urgence contenue d'une
pénurie d'agent dans la ville alors
c'était une urgence mais une urgence
raisonnée que nous avions anticipé avec
ma collègue de plaisir puisque nous
avons la même vision sur la sur la sur
la police c'est-à-dire une police de
prévention et de proximité la ville de
Plaisir dispose et dispose toujours
aujourd'hui d'une police avec un nombre
d'agents conséquent aux Clayes-sous-Bois
nous avions un nombre limité d'achats et
nous voyons bien que pour conserver ces
agents et avoir une police efficace et
augmenter le service vis-à-vis de la
population c'était très très difficile
d'où la nécessité de mettre en commun
des moyens humains des moyens financiers
pour améliorer notre efficacité nous
avons cependant au niveau de la commune
des Clayes-sous-Bois un important
système de vidéourveillance puisque nous
avons déjà plus de 140 caméras et dans
la mesure où nous avions la même vision
avec le maire de plaisir nous ne
pouvions aller
dans son sens néanmoins même si la
police municipale est plus importante à
l'heure actuelle à plaisir nous aurons
un poste aussi aux classes sous bois
comment vous expliquer cette difficulté
à recruter dans la ville des
Clayes-sous-Bois je pense que ce n'est
pas que la ville Les Clayes-sous-Bois je
pense que les policiers municipaux ils
sont attirés par des projets dans des
villes importants avec des moyens
importants et des offres de services
importants il y a une très forte
intégration des territoires entre les
clés et plaisir donc c'était aussi tout
à fait logique d'aller dans cette voie
on va parler d'urbanisme à présent un
des grands projets pour la ville c'est
la réhabilitation et la modernisation
des résidences de l'oeuvre alors où
est-ce que où est-ce qu'en sont les
travaux alors déjà pourquoi pourquoi
cette cette rénovation cette résidence
de l'arbre est à peu près 400 400
logements et à peu près 50 ans nous ne
sommes pas dans la ville des
Clayes-sous-Bois dans ce qu'on appelle
un quartier politique de la ville donc
nous n'avons pas d'aide spécifique qui
de rénover ces quartiers il était donc
important pour nous sur une résidence
vieillissante comme ça de trouver un
accord avec le bailleur Logirep pour
rénover la totalité de cette résiste
cette résidence c'est ce qui va être le
cas avec une rénovation extérieure
intérieure tous les expats extérieurs
également qui va s'étaler entre 2021 et
2027 avec la la suppression de deux
tours mais la
requalification et le réaménagement de
nouveau bâtiments beaucoup plus petit ce
qui va permettre également d'avoir une
mixité sociale plus importante puisqu'il
va y avoir une accession à la propriété
également sur ce quartier donc ça va
être une réhabilitation à la fois pour
cette résidence mais pour l'ensemble du
quartier vous avez dit 400 logements ça
concerne combien de familles environ
400 logements vous avez au moins 400
familles et elles vont être
si vous voulez quelques chiffres en
finale il n'y aura que 35 suppressions
de logement mais c'est logement seront
réattribués au niveau de la ville il y a
déjà un travail très important qui a
fait par le bailleur puisque toutes les
familles ont été reçus ont exprimé leur
souhait de relogements sur la commune ou
pas sur la commune mais la quasi
intégralité c'est sur la commune dans ce
quartier là dans d'autres quartiers
voilà c'est un travail de fourmis qui
est planifié et qui pour l'instant
avance de façon très très bonne au
niveau santé une maison
pluridisciplinaire devrait voir le jour
en 2023
non elle va les premiers travaux
j'aimerais bien qu'elle voit le jour en
2023 mais elle verra le jour que fin
2024 pourquoi fin uniquement fin 2024
ben nous partons d'un bâtiment qui était
existant qui est l'ancienne sécurité
sociale des classes sous bois que nous
allons totalement réaménager nous avons
trois plateaux à l'heure actuelle de 300
mètres carrés nous allons même créer un
quatrième un quatrième plateau puisque
dans le projet global de santé nous
avons un pôle un pôle d'imagerie qui est
prévu pourquoi ce elle est aussi vite
sur cette maison de santé c'était un des
projets phares que j'avais de mon de mon
mandat constatant la difficulté au
niveau du personnel médical et
paramédical de notre commune c'est pour
ça que nous avons débuté dès l'année
2020 a rencontré les différents
partenaires comme la RS que nous avons
créé un une association avec nos
médecins pour de créer le plan de santé
et que nous sommes à l'heure actuelle
dans dans la phase où nous allons
retenir un architecte pour
réaménager cette cette maison plus riche
disciplinaire de santé sachant que nous
sommes classifiés dans une ce qu'on
appelle en terme technique en zone zip
c'est-à-dire une zone très très
déficitaire en médecin vous êtes déjà
des professionnels de santé à mettre
dedans nous avons déjà tout à fait nous
avons déjà puisque nous avons créé une
association et dans cette association
parce que le plan le plan de santé se
sont pas les élus qui doivent qui
doivent le mettre en place ils doivent
ils doivent venir de la part des
médicaments et des paramédicaux et donc
au fur et à mesure que le projet avance
et il avance très très bien aujourd'hui
nous avons de nouveau professionnel qui
viennent se greffer et c'est pour ça que
le plan de santé lui-même ça y est il
est déjà établi il va être déposé il a
été déposé à la RS et nous allons passer
à l'étape suivante ce sont des nouveaux
médecins qui viennent s'installer ou des
nouveaux pour l'instant des médecins qui
sont de la commune il y a des
paramédicaux parce que nous manquons de
pas de paramédicaux il n'a pas que le
médecin généraliste il y a aussi les
paramédicaux par exemple au clair aux
Clayes-sous-Bois nous n'avions pu
quinquiner nous avons deux nouveaux
kinés qui sont qui sont partants pour
ces pour cette maison et nous avons
aussi parmi les médecins actuels des
médecins qui se proposent pour être des
formateurs de nouveaux médecins et qui
donc viendront éventuellement dans cette
maison de santé tout ça est aussi un
travail de longue haleine et alors parmi
les nouveaux équipements une résidence
pour seniors devraient également voir le
jour à proximité du centre-ville tout à
fait une résidence pour seniors qui est
très attendue et je dois dire que Ben
nous sommes satisfaits d'avoir enfin pu
débloquer ce projet puisque il était
bloqué depuis plusieurs années mais à
l'heure actuelle le les terrains a été
vendu les anciens bâtiments qui étaient
sur ces terrains sont en cours de
de destruction le projet le permis de
construire a été accepté et purgé de
tout recours et nous allons avoir la
première pierre dès ce premier semestre
avec un objectif de réalisation de cette
maison pour fin de fin 2024 mais je
pense beaucoup plus raisonnablement
premier semestre 2025 sachant que nous
avons aussi négocié le fait que le
premier tour d'attribution sera aussi
revue pour l'ecclésiens puisque il y
aura dans cette maison 20%
d'appartements qui seront à caractère
social et enfin nous avons aussi négocié
le fait que bien que nous soyons en
centre-ville donc très près du parc de
Diane très près de la forêt la
rétrocession de 700 mètres carrés qui
sera en aménagement paysager et donc
pour terminer cet entretien Philippe
guigan c'est l'interview express
[Musique]
alors le principe cinq questions courtes
5 réponses assez courtes vous pouvez
répondre de soi par oui ou par non soit
pour ou contre je vous laisse 20
secondes à peu près si vous voulez
donner des éléments de réponse est-ce
que vous êtes prêts je suis prêt
augmentez-vous les impôts locaux dans
votre commune en 2023 du coup ça serait
pour la première fois à 13 ans en 13 ans
oui
nous sommes en train de finaliser le
budget cela ne va pas vous surprendre si
je ne peux pas vous donner de réponse à
l'heure actuelle est-ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre la circulation des 30
km/h dans la ville je suis pour une
circulation mais pour une circulation en
fonction des quartiers parce que je
considère qu'il n'y a pas la même
dangerosité dans tous les quartiers et
il faut spécifier cette zone à 30 voire
à 20 sur les quartiers qui sont les plus
accidentogènes est-ce que vous êtes pour
ou contre l'obligation de la cantine bio
dans les villes
je suis pour dans la mesure où on en
donne les moyens aux collectivités un
exercice de vos fonctions est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu peur physiquement
physiquement non je n'ai je n'ai pas eu
peur faut pas préjugés de l'avenir mais
c'était aussi parce que je pensais être
une personne de dialogue et je suis à
l'écoute des gens et on n'hésite pas à
venir me poser des questions et enfin
pour terminer est-ce que vous êtes un
maire heureux à très heureux malgré
malgré les difficultés on a de super
projets à développer sur notre ville
j'ai une équipe qui est extra donc je
suis très heureux pour les trois ou
quatre ans qui restent et bien merci
beaucoup Philippe Viguen d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en plateau je le
rappelle vous êtes le maire des
Clayes-sous-Bois c'est moi qui vous
remercie